[Musique]
bonjour Vianney malins bonjour Patrice
je suis ravi de vous recevoir vous êtes
quelqu'un d'autre on entend beaucoup
parler mais qu'on voit ou qu'on entend
rarement vous êtes un des grands grands
organisateurs de livres c'est l'équipe
c'est l'équipe derrière l'équipe
derrière vous mais voilà enfin vous avez
organisé notamment le salon de livre de
50 ans en Yvelines il y a quelques mois
et puis là des 18 19 et 20 novembre il y
a le Salon du livre de Versailles qui
s'appelle histoire de dire
15e édition 15e édition effectivement je
crois qu'on prend pas trop de RIB parce
qu'on essayait de se renouveler chaque
année donc c'est c'est très concentré
sur tous les deux après midi du samedi
19 et dimanche 14h 18h30 c'est gratuit
c'est ouvert à tout le monde il y a pas
besoin d'être gros lecteur d'être
passionné d'histoire voilà on vient
aussi découvrir un morceau de Pulse de
l'histoire de France et du monde chacun
sa façon alors le fait d'associer
évidemment une histoire à Versailles
comme ça ça peut paraître évident
évidemment
c'est une idée qui est venue tout de
suite quand on a proposé de vous occuper
oui c'était une longue langue intuition
en disant si on doit faire un salon une
fête de l'histoire c'est bien Versailles
bien sûr on pense tout de suite au grand
siècle le château Louis XIV mais pas que
mais pas que voilà parce que la Grande
Boucherie de la grande guerre de 14
c'est fini là le traité de Versailles
l'amendement vallon la naissance de la
République s'est inversé je pourrais
vous raconter plein de choses qui font
que Versailles est au cœur de l'histoire
de France au cœur de l'histoire et et
justement l'histoire c'est aussi
un des un des fournisseurs si je peux
dire essentiel de la littérature que ça
soit que ça soit les romans ou que ça
soit les essais évidemment vous avez
tout à fait raison vous avez tout à fait
raison
je viens de prendre un petit déjeuner
avec Romain de ouf le fils de Michel
Sardou
et il puisse vraiment sa source
d'ambition là d'ailleurs il viendra avec
un essai pour la première fois une belle
réhabilitation du Moyen-Âge voilà oui
c'est ça oui c'est il est passionné par
le moyen-âge ce qui est alors évidemment
dans cette dans cette histoire de lire
vous disiez c'est très varié il y a en
effet des il y a en effet le Moyen-âge
et en effet de l'histoire contemporaine
vous avez un plateau absolument
formidable alors formidable ah oui un
petit peu quand même
soyons fiers après
c'est compliqué de faire une sélection
parce qu'on reçoit 181
quand je dis formidable évidemment et
c'est là où c'est le salon notamment de
vie passionnant ce qui en effet des gens
célèbres des auteurs célèbres et puis il
y a des auteurs qu'on pourra découvrir
on va en parler d'ailleurs parce que
voilà alors dans mes fiertés que je
pourrais quand même citer des auteurs
qui viennent de loin de l'étranger et
qui montre peut-être que avec ces 15 ans
d'existence il y a une certaine maturité
et rayonnement à l'international voilà
je pense à l'un des plus grands
historiens britanniques qui s'appelle
Anthony bivores voilà qui est beaucoup
écrit sur la Seconde Guerre mondiale là
qui viendra avec un livre sur la guerre
civile en Russie en 17 voilà je pense
aussi à une
dire c'est presque d'actualité parce que
c'est quelque part oui quelque part oui
ça peut nous aider à reprendre ce qui se
passe de la Russie au bord de l'Oural je
pense aussi à une des des romanciers les
plus les plus les plus lus du monde
hispanique qui est Arturo Perez voilà
grand grand romancier mais qui a eu une
première vie comme reporter de guerre et
voilà absolument journaliste de guerre
voilà qui nous parlera notamment de la
Bosnie-Herzégovine Alex Yougoslavie
voilà c'est compliqué de faire venir des
voilà des
c'est vrai qu'il faut il faut que le
salon est une existence et notoriété
c'est jamais gagné
parce que le marché par là si on parle
d'Arturo le marché de la Francophonie et
tout petit et souvent assez dates là il
est il y a une grande force du livre au
Mexique qui lui ouvre le marché mondial
d'Amérique du Sud donc on pèse pas grand
chose cette année il a dit allez je
viens Versailles voilà dans les
personnalités étrangères plus proche de
nous nous aurons Maria Teresa la grande
différence
tout à fait avec son ami Stéphane avec
son ami Stéphane l'autre Luxembourg
luxembourgeois
du salon
vous avez raison il adore en tout cas le
château de Versailles et il y a consacré
beaucoup d'émissions et alors il y a
aussi donc il y a beaucoup d'auteurs on
va on va voilà voir un petit peu le
plateau des gens célèbre il y a aussi
beaucoup de débats d'ailleurs qu'ils ont
organisés avec des journalistes siège en
pierre et Cabasse qui publie
Giesbert tout à fait des grands grands
journalistes qui ont été des
observateurs très attentifs de la vie
politique voilà nous avons alors un très
grand monsieur il y a la fille de pardon
de Michel polniettovski vous avez vous
avez raison donc constance vous cherchez
et là et là le débat va être très
amusant c'est le débat d'ouverture du
samedi à 14h entre Elkabbache et
Constance constance qui a eu pour père
donc Olivier Guichard j'allais dire un
baron du gaullisme et qui a épousé et
pour beau-père Michel un prince après du
giscardisme donc si vous voulez
shiracogoli et législas donc c'est
amusant d'avoir
le regard de personnes qui étaient au
premier loge du pouvoir voilà qu'elle
raconte des choses des détails
évidemment qui sont très intéressants
pour l'histoire et qu'on ne connaissait
pas forcément
tout à fait passionnant on va s'amuser
alors autre rencontre qui qui
intéressera peut-être pas forcément un
public plus averti j'allais dire c'est
un grand grand monsieur pas forcément
très connu du grand public qui s'appelle
Pierre Nora voici quand même pour les
historiens c'est ce monsieur qui n'a pas
beaucoup écrit comme historien mais qui
en revanche a peser dans ce pays de
galères
ses amis ce qu'il a accompagné
s'appelait
du BI furet le rôle à la durée de école
historique française va les grandes
écoles parce qu'ils sont pas tous
d'accord forcément voilà c'est bien Dora
et puis il y avait là il y avait la
revue aussi tout à fait donc tout ça
c'est
il va nous raconter l'envers du décor de
45 ans d'édition qui ont pesé dans dans
l'histoire de l'histoire voilà donc
voilà ça c'est évidemment des des stars
du salon je peux dire enfin les gens
célèbre mais il y en a plein il y a
Camille Pascal qui est qui est à la fois
une plume de président de la République
et un très bon auteur de de roman
historique
enfin bon là on a cité jusqu'à présent
les stars qui venaient pour la première
fois mais après on a nos amis nos
habitués effectivement des habitués
Camille Pascal est déjà venu plein de
fois Franck Ferrand Stéphane
vous avez tout à fait raison et puis les
les grandes plumes historiques que sont
Emmanuel devaresquiège Jean-Christian
petit fils voilà tout ça ce sont des des
historiens une grande grande dame
âgée mais qui euh absolument revenir à
l'occasion de la réédition de toutes ces
portraits des des rois Valois enfin
voilà
et et évidemment ce qui est intéressant
c'est le contact pour les auteurs et
pour le public le contact il peut y
avoir entre eux parce que il y a les
conférences en effet où on peut aller
les ou les conférences sur les débats et
puis il y a les signatures on peut aller
leur parler on peut aller ces moments
plus personnels personne ils sont là
vraiment pour cela après ces années
covid d'éloignement d'annulation je peux
vous dire qu'ils sont heureux heureux
heureux de redescendre dans la reine et
de de pouvoir rediscuter avec leur
lecteurs leur public c'est très
important pour eux c'est vrai que ça a
manqué pendant pendant quelques années
ce contactait parce que c'est vrai que
il y a rien de mieux je pense pour un
auteur que d'avoir le d'abord des gens
qui les suivent souvent et qui ont des
choses à leur dire il y a ce contact
direct quoi qui est
par nature l'écrivain il est seul que
c'est lui absolument ils ont besoin de
cette énergie
donc
ce plateau alors
c'est sur trois jours ça commence le
vendredi ça commence le vendredi surtout
pour les scolaires et effectivement on
va recevoir 250 élèves du primaire
pendant toute la journée et ensuite ben
on enchaîne à chaque minute à chaque
quart d'heure il se passe quelque chose
c'est pour ça que j'invite les gens à
préparer leur visite pour éviter la
frustration et qu'il se fasse le même
leur programme des auteurs qui veulent
rencontrer avec qui ils veulent discuter
ou les rendez-vous qu'ils veulent noter
d'ailleurs il y a un certain nombre de
ces rendez-vous notamment les grands
débats notamment les histoires en scène
qui est un jeu avec des comédies en
costume qui lisent des extraits et
l'auteur répond donc là ce sont des
événements il faut réserver absolument
faut prendre sa place sur le site du
salon.fr et sinon on ne rentre pas dans
la place comme cela même si c'est
gratuit salon du livre ça peut plus être
juste un endroit où il y a au parc les
auteurs d'un côté il y a des gens qui
viennent faire signer il faut aussi il
faut aussi le faire vivre alors aussi
des événements vous avez raison voilà on
est on est autre chose qu'une simple
librairie effectivement c'est d'abord un
lieu de rencontre des échanges voilà
c'est ça qui qui nourrit la rencontre en
Suisse voilà et puis il y a des choses
qui sont un petit peu
à côté bon par exemple cette année on va
fêter les 150 ans de la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de Versailles
Yvelines qui ont le président Guillaume
Kerrou absolument donc
est à la manœuvre donc
j'ai écrit conçu un parcours découverte
scénographique dans ce merveilleux hôtel
particulier de la dubarie la dernière
maîtresse de Louis XV et donc voilà le
public alors là il y a pas d'horaire
c'est non-stop de tout le samedi
après-midi et tout le dimanche de 14h
venez découvrir ce lieu magnifiquement
restauré et vous croiserez peut-être la
dubarie elle-même ou monsieur ou
monsieur Bamberger donc un des anciens
présidents qui avaient eu cette
institution que Versailles et les
Yvelines n'étaient pas une chambre de
commerce anodine qu'il y avait une
dimension culturelle et touristique et
c'est pour ça qu'il a acheté cet hôtel
particulier pour en faire le siège de la
Chambre de commerce
du Conservatoire
il y a des malins il y a des choses
presque plus étonnantes dans ce dans ce
salon
il y a notamment vous avez invité
notamment des youtubers on va quelques
petits extraits de de ce qu'on peut
trouver sur Youtube et puis on en parle
juste après
pour ma part j'ai fait mes débuts à la
cour en tant que dame de compagnie de
Catherine d'Aragon
et à ce moment-là Henry avait une
liaison avec ma soeur Marie et un beau
jour il s'est glissé dans les DM il m'a
fait des aventures insta que j'ai
longtemps décliné
pour des raisons qui me regardent et
malgré le fait qu'il semblait très
amoureux et que ses sentiments avaient
l'air de croître de jour en jour
la production principale de toiles à
peindre provient de la région d'Alençon
où il y a une tradition de la culture du
chanvre mais progressivement celui-ci
est remplacé par le lin et la production
se déplace alors dans les Flandres
françaises au 19e siècle apparaîtront
aussi l'étoile en coton mais les
peintres préféreront presque toujours le
lin en fait l'église est continuellement
embellie jusqu'à la fin du Moyen-Âge et
d'ailleurs à ce moment là il va se
passer un moment majeur pour l'histoire
de l'édifice on va être en pleine guerre
de Cent Ans les Anglais et les Français
s'affrontent évidemment les Français
tiennent la ville de Crepy ils sont
derrière les remparts l'église étant
hors les murs les Anglais vont en
profiter pour mettre le pied dedans
utilisez les tours clochers comme point
d'observation pour observer la défense
et malheureusement évidemment l'église
va souffrir elle va notamment être
décapitée elle va perdre ses deux
flèches et une seule d'entre elles va
être reconstruite celle de la tour Nord
qui va devenir ainsi le symbole de la
ville
alors c'est trois petits extraits de
très différent d'ailleurs de ce qu'on
peut trouver sur Youtube le premier
c'était des selfies de Rennes alors
envoyé Anne Bollène qui parlait d'Henri
VII en gros
c'est extrêmement bien fait
ils sont imaginatifs ils sont créatifs
ils sont
irrespects de la télévision classique
c'est évident et donc il y a 5 ans on a
créé donc
surpris des meilleurs youtubeurs
d'ateliers puis le troisième c'était je
crois que ça s'appelle archivolt et nous
faisait visiter une un lieu historique
qui était qui était Denix
candidatures il y a 6 nominés et donc là
vous parliez du programme du vendredi
donc le vendredi soir nous allons
remettre le prix du meilleur youtubeur
dans la sélection des des six c'est à
20h30 et c'est à l'UGC Cyrano à
Versailles avec un jury prestigieux
présidé par
des milliers Aubry de dessous des cartes
d'Arte voilà ça va être serré parce que
les candidats sont excellentes les
sélections c'est c'est absolument
formidable et c'est et c'est vrai que
c'est des c'est à la fois c'est comment
des des jeunes gens des jeunes filles
ils sont parts de l'histoire et et en
font quelque chose qui est évidemment et
regardable évidemment pas par tout le
monde et on fait quelque chose de
formidable quoi de très agréable et du
coup tous ces nominés et d'autres
viennent au salon on a un espace dédié
où il y a des projections où le le jeune
public peut aussi dialoguer directement
avec ses youtubeurs et puis alors
certains
comme
Laurent Turcot de la l'histoire nous le
dira vient carrément du Québec c'est un
youtubeur qui vient de l'autre l'autre
bout de l'Atlantique voilà et puis pour
montrer que
on peut être sérieux et discuté on aura
deux célèbres youtubeurs que sont
Benjamin Briot de la chaîne nota et
donc l'autre chaîne c'est c'est mamy
twins donc là on est avec deux chaînes
une chaîne de gaz de culture générale
mais avec un tropisme histoire très fort
donc ça c'est deux chaînes qui ont qui
ont plus de 2 millions d'abonnés et ils
vont débattre tous les deux voilà sur
cette passion de l'histoire qui peut
encore nous surprendre et notamment
grâce au support de l'image et ça c'est
enfin voilà c'est une des aspects de de
ce salon qui fait qui montre que voilà
on n'est pas juste dans
ce qu'on reprend cette année année vous
êtes dans la modernité totale avec ça
quand même alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que c'est pas la première fois et
beaucoup de ces youtubeurs passent
ensuite à l'écrit donc là c'est le
cercle vertueux parce qu'ils amènent un
jeune public et pas forcément gros
lecteur mais qui a envie de suivre son
son sa vedette et donc voilà c'est donc
moi j'invite beaucoup le jeune public à
venir la remise de ce prix voilà il faut
s'inscrire aussi sur le site mais il y a
encore quelques places donc j'allais
dire dépêchez-vous alors autre événement
un peu différent de la littérature
classique c'est le prix de la bande
dessinée historique alors ça c'est aussi
tout nouveau de cette année alors certes
j'avais on avait observé depuis
longtemps que qui se passait des choses
sur ce terrain là j'allais dire c'est
presque notre ADN de départ en 2008-2009
on n'avait Jacques Martin avec Alexis
Alix pardon voilà donc
là on observe depuis quelques années que
cette BD sort du des maisons d'édition
classique de Glénat de Dupuis voilà et
donc les grandes les grandes éditeurs de
littérature où les ou les maisons des de
décès d'histoire se mettent à faire de
la belle historique donc on va remettre
un prix avec nos amis de la Fondation
Pierre Laffut voilà premier prix à la
meilleure BD historique de l'année
oui le président de c'est Alexis
Michalik tout à fait et donc ce prix
sera remis le samedi à 17h30 à l'hôtel
de ville de Versailles et là aussi voilà
on voit quelques-unes
sélectionnées et en effet là aussi le
domaine d'intérêt est très vaste
historique traitée
différentes quoi vaste et pas toujours
facile
c'est retranscrire d'ailleurs on fera un
débat juste avant la remise du Prix
voilà quand une histoire est diverses
quand elle est complexe comment la
résumer en quelques dessins voilà c'est
un exercice qui est pas simple mais ils
vont nous expliquer les scénaristes et
les dessinateurs comment ils s'y
prennent alors vous dit vous êtes vous
n'êtes pas tout seul pour pouvoir
organiser ce genre de de salon vous avez
une société qui s'appelle RTA
communication c'est ça tout à fait
comment comment vous en êtes venu à
l'organisation de son nom du livre c'est
pas la seule activité de la société non
alors effectivement pour rebondir sur le
début de votre propos on n'est pas tout
seul il y a une équipe pour le salon de
Versailles il y a 102 bénévoles qui
s'impliquent dans l'organisation donc
c'est une c'est une armée j'allais dire
parce qu'il faut bichonner les auteurs
faut s'assurer qu'ils vont se déplacer à
tel endroit
par qui seront accueillis
donc beaucoup de nos bénévoles sont
costumés on veut en faire une fête dans
l'histoire donc donc voilà le livre a
peiné effectivement pendant quelques
décennies c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
retour indéniablement à la lecture
pendant les années covid ou les gens
étaient enfermés chez eux et donc voilà
on souhaite accompagner ce mouvement
mais vous l'avez compris il faut doubler
de de créativité d'initiatives pour
voilà approcher un public plus éloigné
de la lecture des gens ont perdu un
petit peu le
l'habitude de lire mais justement c'est
assez intéressant parce que oui en effet
si on regarde les chiffres voilà ils
disent souvent d'un petit peu moins qui
ne se vendait il y a quelques années et
en même temps des salons comme histoire
de dire
sur des vecteurs de de public c'est à
dire oui il y a un grand public qui
vient qui vient là
c'est un succès quoi ce genre de salon
est-ce que oui évidemment que la
littérature a besoin d'événements comme
ça c'est frotter au public c'est évident
après
voilà il faut il faut aller chercher le
public dans dans ses aspirations donc
effectivement par exemple les gens sont
plus attirés par l'histoire
contemporaine donc il y a une
sur-représentation dans l'édition parce
que le public aime voilà si c'est la
dernière guerre mondiale si ces deux
Gaules vous pouvez être un auteur
inconnu vous pouvez être un tout petit
éditeur vous arriverez en vendre voilà
donc en fait certes il faut pas
éviter il faut aller brosser le public
dans le sens d'une poêle j'allais dire
et en même temps il faut il faut
l'amener bien sûr et après voilà cette
année vous avez sur notre affiche donc
un mandchou voilà ça ne parle pas à tout
le monde mais vous voyez bien que à
travers ce ce visuel très chatoyant on
intrigue et il se trouve que ce cet
empereur mandchou avait l'une des plus
grandes bibliothèques de de l'histoire
et donc voilà on s'est amusé à faire un
petit clin d'oeil au lieu d'être sur son
destrier son cheval voilà il est il est
sur un livre voilà il y a un chinois qui
arrive à Versailles ce qui est quand
même un grand symbole
quels sont les
quels sont les étapes ou les projets qui
sont les vôtres en dehors de de histoire
de lire
ah ben écoutez moi mon métier c'est
c'est depuis 40 ans d'être dans
l'événementiel voilà donc j'organise des
conventions des colloques pour le monde
de l'entreprise ou le nom de de des
fondations des associations voilà je
suis
occupé
d'Octobre rose pour la cause du cancer
mais le tropisme intérieur le le le
cagneux l'étudiant d'histoire voilà et
vous êtes un amour d'histoires et ne
pouvait pas être en fait complètement et
depuis 15 ans je consacre une bonne
partie de mon temps libre voilà à la
lecture et à l'organisation de de salon
et notamment de celui-là voilà vous
allez écrire un jour des mémoires de
d'organisateur de sol c'est un autre
métier c'est un autre exercice
rendez-vous dans quelques années
j'ai encore toute la vie des qualités
pour faire quelques quelques années de
salon encore
une histoire des salons du livre
avec des avec des anecdotes parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a souvent il y a des
auteurs qui ont des des files d'attente
absolument énorme et puis à côté
ceux qui attendent patiemment il y a
toujours une sorte d'injustice comme ça
mais c'est et puis il y a des anecdotes
une solidarité entre les auteurs et puis
secret des des collections très fortes
avec avec le public bon je cite souvent
cet exemple mais de des manuels de
vareskiel qui est une année à un
monsieur en face de lui et qui pardon
pouvez-vous signer tout de suite
dédicacer tout de suite ma femme vient
de m'appeler elle accouche mon fils
s'appellera pouvez-vous dédicacer le
livre en son nom et depuis 8 ans ce
monsieur revient avec son fils et
rachète un livre dédicacé et donc cet
enfant maintenant passe une journée du
salon assis à côté des mails de risque
il l'amitié qui s'est créé c'est plein
d'histoires comme ça aussi
fidélité des lecteurs des gens qui
viennent et puis il était des auteurs
qui vous suivent aussi et qui vous font
confiance donc on parle d'enfance c'est
important c'est important
ce genre manifestation est aussi un
moment privilégié pour donner le goût
dès le plus jeune âge dès le coloriage
d'un personnage historique voilà donner
le goût de l'histoire aux enfants donc
on a un chapiteau une tente dédiée cette
année on aura 41 auteurs jeunesse et un
record
absolu voilà qui s'appelle viviane
Koenig qui s'appelle
des splats du qui s'appelle Christine
Ferri fleuri voilà c'est c'est plein de
gens brillantissimes et puis alors je
suis très fier heureux d'une initiative
on a sélectionné une dizaine de
collégiens de collégiennes qui ont lu et
aimé un livre ah oui se transformeront
en jury en journaliste journaliste
un livre qu'ils ont aimé alors devant
d'autres jeunes publics mais c'est eux
qui seront au micro et qui dirigeront la
rencontre alors j'allais dire voilà
l'avenir est
assuré puisque la jeune génération n'est
plus passif mais mais s'engage dans
l'organisation du salon merci beaucoup
Vianney malins et bravo pour toutes ces
activités puis vous revenez quand vous
voulez ici vous êtes chez vous merci à
vous merci
[Musique]